hi so mostly just a quick update on what
the indicate has gone through in the
last year and a little bit
forward-looking stuff as well as a tiny
bit of advice on the 64-bit transition
that's coming up that's me dan Albert
that's our where we have our bug tracker
and some wiki and some announcements and
stuff so in the last year we've done our
15 and our 16 our 15 is when we switched
over to the new form of the headers
which has the one single blob of headers
that are correct for every API level
instead of having a bunch of bug fixes
only the newest one and the old ones are
just horribly out-of-date and broken our
16 that became a requirement and we
fixed up Lib C++ and Lib Android support
if you were here last year or seen me
talk before if you'll know that lip C++
was really in a beta state in the NDK
because of this live Android support
that we used to back port API is to back
then as early as Gingerbread we've
cleaned all that up so this is now
actually the sto we were recommend in
our 17 it's actually the default we
removed support for arm 5 and the MIPS
flavours which is probably a welcome
change for all of you because it's less
stuff that you have to test our 17 is in
beta right now in theory stable is going
out tomorrow but I haven't spoken to QA
yet today so we'll see it defaults to
Lib C++ it adds the OM r1 API is it has
the PAP is more of those landing
tomorrow
Aysen no longer requires root which is
fantastic you now just have to ship the
shared library in your app and use this
rapid SSH which is an oaf feature to
make sure it gets loaded in your apk LTO
networks on Windows I know it's a huge
thing for game developers so hooray and
apparently we remove those api's again I
think that was our 17 and they were
deprecated in our 16 all right team
we've been working on for a while it
includes client ID support and it also
removes all the old crap that we've been
working on deprecating for the last few
years so GCC the other STL's starting
with our 18 it is clang and it is Lib
C++ and
is it much few far fewer combinations of
the test so everything should be much
higher quality and it should be less
complications of getting all your
middleware to match our 19 this is gonna
be a big change for anyone the room that
maintains a their own build system but
it should be the change that you get to
delete a ton of your code all of the
tool chains are just me standalone tool
chains Android will start working like a
normal cross compiler where you just
call clang you say I'm targeting air 64
26 and it just does the right thing you
no longer have to know all the crazy
flags and the paths to everything yeah
fine translation is complete we are done
with this inside Google all of user
space was clang in Marshall ball most in
marshmallow all of it nougat most some
of the kernels in Oreo it's now it was
the default compiler starting in NDK
r-13 which is a year and a half ago it
is the only one in the next release it's
probably less exciting for this room but
new api's and stuff for lib see the
clang fortify source is a security
measure that maybe people in this room
care about it'll do things like check
buffer overruns above compile time and
some mitigation at run time again P more
api's
cpu profiling we ship simple perf in the
NDK it has for ages had a command-line
interface but in the studio 3.1 it's got
a UI way just looks like that we the
command-line tool itself can spit out
these flame graphs which are really cool
helpful helpful for drilling down into
what exactly is going wrong updates on
command-line tools to onp got a whole
bunch of new things in toy box adb has
been sped up on USB 3 and like I said
advice on the 64-bit transition we're
not trying to create fire drills here
it's a really for the
they only have to run one zygote if you
have a 64-bit only device if there are
any reasons why you Kate why you can't
hit the 2019 deadline on that let us
know we do want to know about that and
we'll work with you to try to sort that
out the 64-bit transition does come with
some performance improvements if Tim is
still in the room he can maybe hint at
what they are because I don't know
numbers five to 10% okay that was my
guess and now that'll vary based on your
application obviously having the higher
minimum in SDK version since 64 bit on
that came in L you can't target anything
lower than L which means you have newer
API is available
you don't need live Android support and
we are working with all the engine
companies to make sure that their
engines are 64-bit ready by the time
this happens so you know who you are and
for the actual how to port your code to
64 but we found these three really
helpful when we reporting the platform
it'll catch the cases where oops you
were using an INT instead of a pointer
or oops you're using a pointer instead
of an int implicit function declaration
is a fun one because C for in all of its
wisdom decided that a function that was
not defined had the return type of int
which is very frustrating when it
actually returns a pointer because it
will just truncate it and your code will
explode